how do you feel about this Monet's dumb
teenagers making out personally I've
been watching the brothers since like
middle school maybe ten years ago I've
been watching it for the past four
seasons this is my second year watching
it's I'm a newbie but the second that I
watched it I was sold you've been
watching since the beginning I've been
watching since the beginning so I got
back here I saw Wow I came to the Big
Brother kind of in one of the later
seasons I know go to a viewing party for
the system premiere and finale it's like
a game of chess but with more dimensions
and like physical humans and also
there's always like really really hot
Ned
so like I can't be mad about that
there's drama there's friendship games
like everything you could want I like
that it's like a basic concept but then
like just completely bizarro that
happens I'm not into sports Zakas and I
feel like this is our Super Bowl that we
can share together yeah the characters
on the show are like out of this world
craziest but we've all been familiar
with slop I don't know what it's made of
but it's some disgusting thing that's a
punishment for what's called to have not
so if you're a have-nots for the week
you probably failed at a competition or
something did you like make you like
kind of go insane so they do that too
like making a week and not do well in
competitions and to like not be on your
game mentally I've tried anything you
can put in your mouth what do you think
will have been worse than what we're
allowed to eat pig face oh okay
it literally looks like some [ __ ] you
would feed a goddamn bird or like the
hours and they did an interview and
there's like oh I always thought slop
was oatmeal but it's not there's other
stuff in it there's other elements to it
it really thought it was alright it's
not like change
it smells like look No
I was like cream of wheat but without
the sugar or flavor is it it looks so
much like cat vomit oh yeah it seems
like pasta and oatmeal had a baby and
forgot the cinnamon it's nothing
some dirty feet
[Music]
it smells like healthy organic like
something like someone would eat on a
cleanse we go for it let's go for it
Christ oh yeah it's a little green here
they thought of of you it has zero
flavor
let's wife's ah gosh very dense and dry
why is it so chewy I'm gonna need about
20 minutes how the [ __ ] did I eat that
for a week it's drying up my mouth
joette Joe ass Joe it's not even like
chewing the consistency there's just
like slightly resemble no it's very
resembling of sand sandy yeah eating
sand that's what it is it's like eating
same here for sure imagine like making a
beautiful bath of quinoa and like a
greeny wet paste that you're gonna use
to like a [ __ ] your wall that's what I
needed they can like add stuff to it but
it's gross I mean you need to add a damn
steak to this [ __ ] for me to eat it some
salt would be free off would be great
there is no salt in this whatsoever
literally anything you put on this would
make it taste better because that's how
boring it is it has like why are you
going in for another bite this would be
tough to eat all week I would be out to
their mouths like there's no damn way I
would eat this [ __ ] [ __ ] survive done
I don't do that I mean fro for a week
though I mean I feel like I'd start to
go a little crazy after three days I
could do it but I would be such an angry
person by the end of it my spear would
be broken
only eat this for as long as I have to
for a half-million dollars you can do
the full three months I can definitely
make it better
yeah I'm just happy it didn't make me
vomit I feel bad for them now I think
it's way worse than I expected
Oh loaders grab your life vests cuz this
is this Gus thing it's actually not as
bad as I thought it was gonna be like I
thought I was gonna spit this out like
do I got something if I finish the bowl
no that's so bad